hey guys welcome to the vfx breakdown
for century sabotage yeah we're gonna go
over all the great effects we did such
as the cloaking and invisibility
the sentries stuff and we're also gonna
do some other cool things like how did
sam change costumes
magically it turns out it was like magic
this is how we did it
first shot was a handheld shot so i'd
run it through boujou and get a motion
track first then i took that motion
track into 3ds max for my sentry rockets
and tracer elements
and then into after effects where i
stock footage elements like muzzle
flashes smoke and explosions then i
stabilized the shot a little bit because
it was pretty shaky and then color grade
this shot was a similar process but he
did a frozen in time effect so we just
had alex here stand still and then
motion track it throw in our 3d elements
as if everything is frozen in time
and there you have it pretty simple a
little bit of stabilization to smooth
things out a little bit of color grading
to make things look pretty
now for the cloaking effect there were
two variations the first is where i'd
rotoscope myself out of the shot then i
would use that layer to apply a
displacement effect to a background
image
the second variation is used when it's
harder to cut me out of the shot because
the camera is panning for a long time
and there's objects moving in front of
the screen we had to shoot me on a green
screen for this particular shot here
so after tracking the shot and adding
the elements in we would line my green
screen plate up with the shot as best as
possible and then used the same
displacement effect from earlier the
same effect is also used in this shot
except it's in 3d space since the camera
is moving forward
so i shoot myself on a green screen
track it into the shot
and apply the same displacement effect
now the disguise effect was very fun to
shoot basically we'd take two shots one
of me is the spy and one of me is the
soldier in both of these shots there are
specific marks on the ground that i'm
stepping on also i have a metronome in
my pocket so my walking speed is
consistent then we take the shot shot on
a tripod then track it into the moving
shot
after messing around with it a bit
getting the shots to overlap a little
bit put some smoke effects in there and
we're done
a really important thing to do when
compositing 3d elements is to make sure
that you tweak the colors so that it
matches your background footage
for example when i rendered the sentry
out of 3ds max it was too bright and the
blue is too strong you can see how i
changed it to better fit the scene
for the sentry destruction shot
basically all i did was split up the
century into multiple elements and do a
basic physics simulation on it the
physics caused it to kind of burst apart
and then fall to the ground like it
naturally would once your 3d element has
been color tinted to match the raw
footage you'll then go and color grade
the entire shot this gives everything a
final layer of polish and really ties
everything together nicely that was
really cool i hope you guys liked it
that's how you do it go outside and pick
up a camera and shoot a video it's nice
outside right now ain't it nico
yep hey wait if you have any more
questions make sure you hit us up on
either twitter or facebook we've got
links up here we've got links up here we
have links down here what's this one
still links here they're all actually in
the description
there's a link right here too